okay I was just having some technical
difficulties but things should be better
now
I got logged out of twitch I forgot my
password
Safari okay so I should be live feel
free if you're already watching say hi
in the chat this will be intended to be
a Q&A stream so I'll be answering any
type of question maybe people are free
to ask any type of question I don't know
if I'll be able to answer everything but
we'll see how it goes so I'm just
observing the talk game here okay white
one let's do a puzzle it's wait for
people to come and I'll try and boost my
puzzle rating a little bit I had a I had
a good streak until this one but I made
up the points now what was my rating
writing is 25 17 trying to zoom in there
just to show proof hey it's tabby cat
meows welcome to the chats
okay so let's try and focus for a moment
here there's so many people trying to
distract me but I won't give in to
temptation let's let's solve this so
Knight takes e4 was the last move just
creating a ton of chaos because now the
bishops are starting each other there's
three attackers on the Knights the first
thing that comes to mind is just Bishop
takes you for because this Bishop is
hanging and then if Bishop takes you
forward rook takes you for it we can
defend the bishop and be up a piece this
looks really easy then another move
White would like to play is this but it
runs into this this this this is just a
trade and White's down a pawn in the end
it's gotta be Bishop takes you for as if
d5 we just take on you seven blocks not
count you're attacking the Queen all
right moment of truth what don't allow
oh we keep going
so route takes e4 it's probably the
right move I mean we can consider this
but then there's this and again blacks
counter attacking and that would be good
for blacks so let's take with the rook
success it's a miracle
okay it's a framing off I can shrink
this a little bit let me know if look
things look okay and sound okay so shift
this over a little bit okay
so hello to people hello look hook's you
run one two I can't answer your first
question I'm sorry
domination this is Lee chest org
dreamfall lost three games today well if
you lost three games today you hopefully
gained three lessons assuming you have
the right approach to losing zypher is
back well welcome back cyber I ain't obz
good afternoon it's actually evening
here
it's 907 p.m. I am a Geum long time no
see Juan dream domination going for
distractions whoa we have a Ethiopian
viewer whose name I can't pronounce what
time is it in Ethiopia they probably
afternoon rites Capablanca did not know
any opening theory
well theory was just different back then
I'm sure he knows some theory but
probably doesn't know much modern theory
could God make a door he can't open
to make a door that I can't open I'm
terrible with doors and keys it's a real
struggle I really don't know toriel
noggin is back 24 of 24,000 bits I was
like 24 bits I would be doable what's
the next batch you already have the bit
leader what more do you want
there's a pod tie if it only has a one
noodle no it's got to be multiple
noodles but I don't know the exact
number at least two probably what are
these questions I was hoping to have
like an instructive like discussion
stream where I I answer like opening
questions I got questions all the time
from people asking about openings or
specific positions so hopefully we get
some some better your questions like
squeegee from Melbourne more potty
questions if you're eating pad thai in
Thailand is it just pod they call it pot
I hear the problem is Pattaya is
actually a little bit difficult to find
and a lot of like these like kind of
street side restaurants are serving like
seafood and rice and at least so far
I've had to put in a little bit of
effort to find pad thai but not too much
effort we have a viewer from Greece
hello George
natural science or social science
probably both but if I had to choose
probably Natural Science and we have a
sub klunder burg 82 thanks for subbing
Starbucks and Thailand how do you know
there's so many Starbucks
like you walk like I walk like a block
away there's a Starbucks and I walked
two blocks away there's another
Starbucks there's a lot of McDonald's to
which I've avoided completely but
Starbucks it's hard to avoid
why are you 2100 puzzles Tanaka the
chests the puzzle rating is inflated I
will say like my puzzle rating is 25 23
which is a bit higher than my actual
rating but I know for other people it's
there's a much larger gap which is okay
it's just kind of a different the puzzle
rating is different than other ratings
because you're not competing against
people just competing against yourself
basically okay let me make a study I
finally see a chess question study a new
study okay what do I call this answering
question it's from a twitch chats just
so people in the future know where that
questions are coming from it's complete
completely public so people will have
access and the first question let me
just copy and paste this but people
can't see so I'll make a comment which
Sicilian line do I like the most for
black if you're asking like personally I
really like the time on earth it's been
in my repertoire for galibi since high
school
it's 2010 it's been my repertoire for
like the last eight or nine years which
goes he six music's first of all isn't
the most mainstream move I mean if we
had to rank the Sicilian variations and
popularity let me just make a list most
popular Sicilian variations number one
would be night or number two would
probably be be dragon 3 would be
Smashing akov maybe people can use
opening reference together a better more
precise ordinary and then four would
probably be like on slash time on of
which starts with E six and I started
playing the time olive because at least
are the level below 2000 a lot of
players just aren't prepared for it this
is essentially the starting position of
time on of if we want to move further
after a Knight c3 I play Queen c7 now B
chess is calling it the Paulson
variation but as far as I know this is
like the start of time on earth switch
this to in line
[Music]
and there's lots of ideas usually black
is going for some setup involving a 6 9
F 6 and then deciding if the bishop
comes to before or Bishop comes to you 7
and in some cases black can take and put
the Bishop on c5 and then very often
black will play b5 Bishop b7 so it's
just a different way of developing but
there's a lot of theory and I think
there's a good book if anyone wants to
learn this opening there's a book by
Dell Jeff called the safest Sicilian
which I don't like the title so I
wouldn't call this like just a safe
opening I would say it's more dynamic
but it's very good book offers a lot of
great preparation I'd recommend it for 4
players probably 1,800 plus what to do
when you're upset after losing too many
games just go in the corner and cry and
then okay the serious answer
after losing so many games probably
first of all take a break I have seen
people especially when they apply online
like they'll get in like a losing streak
and then they'll just try to keep
playing
- getting rating back and then they keep
losing and then it's just a terrible
cycle so take a break but then make an
effort to like come back and try and
examine why you're losing like try and
identify what's going wrong in your
games and how to improve if you can take
a lesson away from every loss and every
every loss should make you stronger it's
important to acknowledge that losing is
part of getting better I've probably
lost more games than most people in the
chats combines maybe with exception of
some people but you know to become a
good player you have to lose a lot but
you need to lose kind of with the right
mindset
tell us why the exchange really is so
awesome is that a question that's more
of a command well new chapter I mean why
it's so awesome
it's so awesome because look at the
people who played it Carlsen oh wait
Carlsen it's black wait this is not a
good score at the top level at least
other these four games no I
okay so the exchange ROI is played
because white goo is for like this
long-term positional play where okay
usually like castles let's say black
play some move okay there's a lot of
like natural development moves let's say
Bishop d6
and then after here it takes takes even
though white can see that the bishop
here
white just has better structure which
can be used later on in endgame and to
demonstrate one of white strategies it's
useful to actually understand some
endgame positions there's one of the
white strategies is just to trade off
everything and get into a keen plot
ending or even if you get like some King
rook ending or some King minor piece
ending and the pawn pawns basically stay
like this where black has this this
crippled majority and then White has the
uncoupled four-on-three majority the
long-term winning a plan for White's
is to make a pass pawn on the King side
and then just win so to demonstrate this
let me make a new chapter here and we'll
just get rid of the pieces
it's off it's common that like the
e-pawn can be traded for that pawn I can
get some position like this maybe what
scheme can be more centralized might
we'll do some stuff with the pawns
essentially when you play the exchange
Roy you want to aim for some sort of
endgame like King pawn ending like this
is almost completely winning I think it
is completely winning if you know the
right strategy well let me shift the
board over a little bit so framing okay
can size it down I don't want to
embarrass myself but I will say like
this is a position I should beat anyone
in including stock fish as White's so
let me try for those who don't know it
like if you have a position like in a
study here analysis board and you want
to play it out in stock fish I'll go to
the menu here continue from here or play
with machine and let's let's crush some
fish I'll be white I don't think it's
too hard like I just push pawns and and
it's my move
okay so let's start with this activate
the King ah this is actually yeah murmur
it brings up a good point this is
similar to the Berlin - with block
having the damaged structure okay so
we're gonna activate the king and then
very soon play a four and then g4 f5
if h5 will play h3 preparing g4 inclined
to play a four here
just shut black down maybe there's no
reason let's play g4
okay now very soon I want to play f5
could maybe throw it and c5 just
blockade the pawns even more yeah let's
throw and c5 I'll play a 3 B 4 there's a
problem for black is a passed pawn can't
be created on the Queen side and now I
can go for this okay I have to be a
little bit careful let's do this
okay now the goal is to run up with a
pawn and then make a queen or actually
maybe not make a queen but just use this
pawn as an eventual decoy and very soon
I'll start running and with all the
pawns so yeah I can keep waiting
and now now we can calculate the pong
race but white should just be very very
fast
it's always so satisfying to beat
stockfish even if it was relatively easy
easily winning position it's talking to
resign though and play this out until
the death I make two queens
I could make Knight in Bishop to late
now
watch stock fish just like stall and not
move when I have made in one okay mate
is about to come okay so that's why the
exchange ROI is so awesome if you get to
some later and game you can win in style
against stock fish okay I got very far
behind in the chats
I shall maybe leave a link to the study
in the chat in case people want to play
around you go back was this twitch
chance
yeah if if you ever come across a beach
house study and you want to make a clone
just click this and then click clone and
then you'll have full access okay let me
answer some more questions
oh man I'm scrolling up here I'll try
and go in order I think the the time
delay is only like 10 seconds but I'm so
far behind in the chat that I'm reading
comments from from several minutes ago
how long till I become a GM probably
forever favorite Netflix series series I
mean I benched Breaking Bad but that was
not an original Netflix series but it's
probably my favorite thing Netflix and
its bits but I can't see make this
bigger
thanks coward Claude the hundred bits
what's my second favorite opening for
whites assuming that London is my
favourites second favorite opening
probably Grand Prix attack against
Sicilian I did the video probably about
two years ago now for the st. Louis
chess club and I covered a bunch of
different lines oops
need to clear the position a new
position okay
but yeah the the position arising after
efore c5 Knight c3 I've started playing
this when I was 14 years old 15 years
old I think I started because I saw some
really nice game between nigel schwartz
and the player named Hossein also
grandmaster and it was just some clues
Sicilian where like it plays g3 Bishop
g2 just gets a very very solid setup but
short one like a really nice positional
battle where like the whole game was
very very well controlled if anyone
wants to see that game I can maybe
Google it real quick
Nigel Schwartz Hossein yeah I'm pretty
sure it's this one here's a good trick
with with me chess if we just copy the
link go back to Lee chess add a new
chapter paste the link it should pop up
better pop up it didn't pop up maybe I
grabbed the wrong link okay let's try
again okay this should be the right link
yeah this brings back such good memories
every so often I'll revisit this game
such a nice game now I will say there is
a difference between close Sicilian and
Grand Prix and sometimes I go back and
forth I think I probably play a lot more
Grand Prix on streams where do I plays
earlier f4 and then Knight f3 and the
bishop develops hearing but if I had to
classify this opening as a whole I just
call it Knight c3 Sicilian to show one
really nice moment in this game one
really weird looking move that a lot of
normal human beings would never even
consider coming up and in this position
white to move I know that notation is
right there so I think a lot of people
would play like f4 or maybe each three
g4 but short play the move which really
shows like his deeper underlying
understanding here which is Knight c1
which is a very weird looking move on
the surface but the point is to play
Knight d1 her weird looking move and
then to play c3 and just keep this night
away and not allow the knight to trail
off and then the problem emerges for
black because the plan was to play
Knight d7 to c6 the Knights can kind of
get in the way of each other that's
where that happened before a 91 c3 the
light was forced away and black had just
less active play and then later light
expanded on the Kings side and then I
think also traded off the bishops and
eventually won
okay let's move on more questions how do
you handle a position that black keeps
trying to close up I mean sometimes the
position just gets closed naturally and
you have to deal with it
I mean closed positions are not the end
of the world and they're part of chess I
know some players prefer open positions
some players prefer closed positions
positions get closed because okay the
the pawns can get into Lots so if you
prefer open positions sometimes you want
to choose some openings where there's
some more more trades in the center at
least earlier on but it's hard to answer
that question without like seeing a
specific example which is one thing I
would encourage people to do like if you
have specific questions like moments and
games make an effort to save the games
and then if you save them for a stream
like this and I can better answer
questions okay how to counter Sicilian
opening oh I just I think I just
answered that play Knight c3 if you play
Knight c3 and just know the setup I
think it's really solid like Bishop e3
Queen d2 put the pawn on that for very
solid sutta and then if you want to find
high level games just look in the
masters database maybe pull out the
first few moves like choose g3 here and
now look at some strong players all
right I'm very far behind in the chats
so I'm gonna scroll down I'm still
trying to answer questions from both
before a coward pawns here the hundred
bits which is a while ago
okay let me go I'll go with most recent
question I'll try and work my way back
do I play a Danish and do I play gambits
and over the board tournaments only
sound gambits was the last dammit I
played okay let me try and answer this
last camera that I played just DB if
people ever want to like stock mine over
the board games go to chess DB can
download the PG n or can you can just
use their their tool oh this game this
game I kind of play the gambit my but my
opponent declined it I'm gonna pick one
of these for bring until be chess
yeah actually none of these were gambits
was this for getting the opening ah this
game I opponent play the gambits he
sacked on c4 Oh people can't see and I
just played b5 to the fence I'm trying
to like think that when I played a real
gambits no no he's working that's really
okay so let me show I mean this game was
technically like some sacrifice we we
drew in 14 moves because I was tired and
I was not in good physical shape to play
chess where is my study okay
answering questions
the last gambit actually so
interestingly enough the game was in a
Grand Prix Sicilian so for all the
people asking about Grand Prix Sicilian
maybe this will offer some inspiration
because the line I played in this game
was a lot I had never played previously
like not even online previously and it's
a line I only discovered like a month or
two ago maybe two months ago
it starts from kind of a traditional
Grand Prix set up Bishop going to c4
I've shown this in some like online
lecture and now this is a moment where I
play d4 I mean it's a somewhat exotic
pawn sacrifice and I will say it's
pretty dangerous if black is an amateur
player it just doesn't know any theory
and my opponents just started taking a
lot of time from this moment and he was
able to come up with the best line over
the board which is why I agreed to a
draw so so early but there's a very nice
demonstration for white between research
and MVL which I'll go ahead and insert
here where mvl accepted the gambits and
greece ship won in like 20 something
moves we should note that white is just
giving away this pawn I mean there's
three attackers and only two defenders
but like gives away the pawn for
initiative so what happened in that VL
game is black took and then white just
develops and for losing a paw and white
has activated the Queen has opened the D
file while allowing rook t1 also
preparing f5 or if if lines start
opening up there's there's lots of
pressure already some x-ray vision
against F pawn and for the person asking
earlier about like what to do when when
your clone closes down the position you
want to look for pawn breaks especially
if your pieces are in good squares you
want to look for pawn breaks to open up
the position so the go to pawn break is
is f5 and coming up after 97 so I
remember studying this nvl game in
preparation for the game that I played
and grisha played rook a d1 but I think
it turns out that f5 is just so much
stronger because White's already
threatening f6
and if black takes white takes back she
what's the line here oh yeah white takes
back still threatening out six and if
black takes with either neither Bishop
there's g4 and White's just winning like
on the spots I think the computer
approves the f5 I mean plus 1.7 is just
a decisive advantage so in my game my
opponent took with a pawn which is a
best move and I eventually went it back
I play Knight b5 and Bach doesn't really
have a great way to defend the pawn b5
is way too greedy I think I could I mean
I could just take and play Knight g5 and
now f7 is attacked three times only
defended by the king so my opponent gave
back the pawn I played Bishop b3 first
to not allow any t5
ideas and that was just a normal
position so not the most exciting
middlegame emerging from this sort of
opening but it was still fun to play
over the board so this is something that
if people want to kind of learn on their
own I would recommend studying the games
that have been played in this line and
then using stockfish to explore the the
sharper variations too because sometimes
sock fish can find some some novelties
are just some newer ideas okay let me
try and look at some more questions
can I show how to play the qgd I feel
like I've shown this in many previous
videos because I play it as one of my
main openings yeah there's one video I
can point you towards it's called black
wins against e4 and I mean we could just
google it black wins against d4 I give a
lot of insight and how to play like huge
IDI and also yeah this video so if
people want can look at this let me copy
the link
I'll just make a new chapter of playing
against d4 I'll just make a comment here
to that video ah but it shares a Google
link so there okay that's better and
each house actually this is amazing
feature which I feel like more people
should use but if you're watching a
YouTube video and you want to do like
your own analysis you can just watch in
the same window because it embeds I
think it should resize yeah resizes it's
so nice and then you can play along and
you stock fish and see all the the moves
that I maybe recommends incorrectly or
correctly another resource which should
still be on the chess let's go back to
study if you go Toby chess studies and
you type in how to play against one d4
he gets this one yeah it's this one
where I give a lot of like Queens gambit
declined preparation with with
annotations people can't see the
chapters tab but now people can maybe
all let me reframe things a little bit
should have done this before I started
alright
is that better that should be better it
right now people can actually see like
the whole interface Center stuff sure
might have a little bit I think that's
better
I just wanted to show like the chapter
tab and so I do give like Queens gambit
declines recommendations because when
you play Queens gambit declined there's
a few different variations exchange
variation when white takes immediately
and you get some classic structure and
then there's some other lines where like
white takes immediately and then goes
for this Queen a3 move and then I give
recommendation against London to which
is one of my favorite openings to play
as black so okay so I'll leave a link to
this study in the other study just
making you come in here it should be
below the video study how to play
against one
okay okay more questions
Oh how to play against closed Sicilian
but you want me to answer this quickly
okay I'll give you one very quick
recommendation how to play against
closed Sicilian I'm gonna try and keep
this response like below a minute this
is very simple recommendation so let's
say you're a Sicilian player and you're
encountering Knight c3 my recommendation
is to a6 which looks weird but the idea
is to discourage the bishop from
developing so you avoid any like
dangerous Grand Prix attack line and if
white allows you like let's say Y plays
g3 then you play be fine
and you just gain space immediately
white plays Bishop g2 played Bishop d7
and then very often you go for 406 in d5
like if t3b 645 and I enjoy this for
black if white takes you can play Knight
f6 then recapture with the Knights
because the pawn is pinned and otherwise
if white plays e5 and then you can play
h5 and then Knight h6 Knight f5 and then
white can't really get in g4 and it's
actually a very nice position your
bishop goes to e7 I goes to c6 Queen
goes to b6 you can expand further and I
played this this sort of structure many
times and online games and some over the
board games with the very good success
curious if I have any games in novi
chest out of this
maybe I have the game with 9h six I
probably do just these people are too
high rated so and this is one thing like
with any sort of opening sometimes the
most difficult part is like getting a
good recommendation but then once you
have the recommendation then you can
start exploring on your own and use a
database and come in build your
repertoire from there what tee am i
drinking that's a great question if
anyone can guess the treat the tea that
I'm drinking I'll answer whatever they
whatever question they want but you have
to guess correctly and if no one guesses
correctly maybe I'll just end the stream
we chests so awesome yeah I mean the the
interface here is incredible it's just
more awesome that everything is free -
okay this isn't a question but I'll just
add as a chapter because I feel like
people should know how does me chess
make money and maybe more importantly
how to donate to me chess me chess runs
completely on donations and why I'm only
like sharing this not because they they
pay me or anything just because I feel
like people should know but if you want
to like donate Toby chess or buy their
swag it's hard to find on the slice and
you have to have to dig because it's not
like in any of the top men you've always
you have to scroll all the way down and
you have to scroll even further down
than my my window shows where is it
I'm trying to zoom in oh yeah here we go
so you can like they have a patron
program or the swag store so it's useful
if you want to keep me chests from
running Oh what happened this is another
study okay oh I forgot to look at the
tea the tea guesses all this chat okay
yeah no one's getting it correctly I'm
drinking very obscure tea bubble tea
Earl Grey green jasmine chamomile
peppermint no one's right along no
Starbucks is the closest answer give
some hints the hints it's like one of
these weird tea fauna brands that most
people probably have never heard of
before and I've never actually seen it
in the US I've only seen it I think in
Indonesia and now Thailand's
control-f in case I missed it no the the
tea that I'm drinking it's called
Emperor cloud and mist or clouds and
mist it's really good like it's not one
of like these strong like overpowering I
don't even know it is a green or black
people want to Google this yeah I was
not lying the problem though I ordered a
venti and they put they put two tea bags
in the tea so it was actually a little
bit strong like two tea bags at big tea
bags too but it's very good it's like
what I'm taller 50 and it's um just so
calming okay these questions
I'm not taking challenges I'm sorry wait
I saw a question but now I lost it Oh II
45-mile 3d5 asked by Ches Kudo this is
called the elephant gambit right how to
play against elephants and it
pretty sure this is elephant candidates
yeah elephant candidates honestly I
don't think I've ever seriously studied
this or if I have I've just forgot
but I think what I can do I can maybe
show how I would go about studying this
first of all let's go to masters
database let's see what good players
play okay he takes d5 if it's the most
played move in highest scoring I usually
stick with it I know the main point for
luck is to play e4 and God some
initiative again Queen e2 very
high-scoring and this is a very good
sign if like all the top players are
winning as whites then we probably want
to follow them so if I was building a
repertory I'd probably include like
Knight f6 but also Queen e7 and just go
through like the main lines start with
nine f6 okay so d3 logical but Knight c3
even higher scoring so sometimes when
there is like a couple options I'll just
get some inspiration from the games open
some games in new tab and let's see so
this is most seccion this is a blitz
game
why wouldn't MV oh hey the elephant
gambit oh yeah this is the world blitz
championship in 2010 so a while ago
okay so Knight c3 takes weights just up
upon Queen D 1 is actually illogical
sometimes cabinets like this you just
want to grab a pawn and be happy
complete development and black out some
initiative not not too much so that was
Knight c3
I would also use stockfish here just
give some initial impression and we'll
have it give like three lines I might
jump around a little bit okay d3 and 93
are pretty close
let's look at one more game
okay so this is a game with d3 it seems
like black just equalized like no
problem
yeah let's go back let's go back to the
opening book back to stockfish and we'll
just stay with the sock fish move and
see how this unfolds so Queen takes d5
and yeah that game with Knight c3 just
doesn't seem right or no it was d takes
e4 didn't seem right ooh Knight g5 what
is Knight g5 sometimes if the top stock
fish move is like a very rare move then
I'll look into it a bit deeper now I'm
also seeing like 92 is quite playable as
well I'll stick with 92 knight c6 d
takes you for h5 Queen b5 looks nice in
Queen d5 it's a type of move maybe it's
harder to figure out just over the board
but um I mean if light can trade Queens
and just hold on to the pawn and it's
nice I should c5 like Knight b3 just go
for some trade but Knight b3 gives back
the pawn well maybe it's still
comfortable there's also a 5 here which
might objectively be better way e5
almost wins apiece Black has to move the
knight to defend the bishop mmm-me 6
nice move
f take c6
it's a white gave back a pawn but now
black is left with a very ugly pawn on
e6 I like this move Knight e4 which is a
novelty maybe add a small annotation
here novelty where why just has nice
development some attack on the bishop
and that we should know that the bishop
is pinned so white is pretty much
guaranteed to get the bishop hair looks
like a six is a move a six Queen c4 now
attacking me six looks like White's
maintaining some edge there's better
structure some initiative
so I could expand on us further like I
could spend an hour of just looking at
this opening and it's sometimes the type
of opening you're gonna run into very
rarely so you just want something simple
hey it's bits with a question I'll get
to that question in the moment but yeah
you only get to the point where you just
you can remember this even if you
encounter this like months from now so
okay so we allow e4 we play Queen e2 we
attack we win back the pawn and then
Queen B fives probably what I would try
to to commit to memory then ePHI v6 is
just icing on the cake okay yeah
hopefully that gives the starting points
at least what's the difference between
the polar bear and the birds opening
also thank you naked yet e99 for the
bits I don't know if I'm the best person
to answer this because I was asking my
asking this to myself like a little
while ago difference between the bird
and polar bear I mean as far as I know
they start off the same way I mean the
bird is just at four I move one bird
opening but then I mean the ultimate
goal will be to make me chest a polar
bear so let's say D 5 and then B 3
like nine of six pretty sure like this
is the polar bear is when you put your
Bishop on the diagonal and then go for
control over a five so I think this is
polar they're almost type to pull guard
they're polar bear maybe someone can
correct me but I don't know
hey he owe me in the chats welcome back
heel meeting but yeah the idea is to get
just some simple setup sometimes even
Bishop d3 and you go for like some King
side attack I think King crusher places
a decent amount but yeah I don't think I
can add too much more it can also be
like over reverse touch like depending
how play unfolds I'm scrolling up here
because they feel like I missed a lot
but okay let me try let me try and
answer some easy questions what's your
favorite e4 e5 opening as whites against
weaker players probably pawns eonni
against stronger players I have three
favorites so ok favorite e4 e5 opening
openings for lights ok favorite number
one I'll just show the openings without
going too deeply Ponzi Ani great opening
to teach beginner is very simple white
wants to play d4 and dominate the center
over the number two which I like to play
a lot in blitz is for Knights with a
three
because there's lots of tricks just to
show some tricks just for inspiration
first trick I well what do we call this
well the Gunzburg variation yeah
trick number one if black plays Bishop
c5 Center for trick this is already
better for white Bishop c5 is dubious
trick number two if black play is like a
six or a Bishop e7 like we'll play d4
and you basically get a fortnight scotch
where black can't access b4 for the
bishop and then one more trick if black
plays d5 which is objectively the best
move then white can take black takes
back and then very interesting move here
Knight takes e5 which if black hasn't
seen before I played this a good number
of times and blitz including against and
routing and some Bulleit game where it
confused him a little bit and then like
I just want to pawn early the point
being if Knight takes there's Queen e2
and then all all the players will take
on c3 and then white just wins the pawn
takes and then you win this and just
better endgame
but if I'm playing it like a in a
high-level tournament and I want
something more reliable and something
with just a better reputation usually
plays Spanish and Spanish can branch out
into so many different things but yeah I
guess weaker player isn't against like
against people in blitz I'll play you a
Ponzi on here this four nights with a
three have I already made a study how to
play against the French I don't think I
made a complete study still working on
that what do I recommend for a four for
an 1100 player I usually recommend
either just King's pawn to e4 e5 or
Sicilian maybe I can give one quick
recommendation in Sicilian
recommendation 464 1100 rated player
very simple variation I think we would
call this a four-night Sicilian you can
start with e six and this is mainly for
open Sicilian play might have six attack
in the pawn I like to recommend this
because there's a few traps first trap
of white plays 85 there's Queen 85 check
the second trap if Knight c3 actually
we'll get to the trap later but black
can play knight c6 and now we have a
four Knights and the trap is more more
positional where while the players will
just try and develop normally and I
played this ship to e3 natural looking
move and then black can play Bishop b4
and then it's a very easy position to
play for black because d5 is coming
the center is breaking down
if I play is like Bishop d3 still d5
very often black wants to play e5 and
just expand in the center so I think
this is a relatively simple simple line
to play if you're just starting out okay
this is tiring I don't think there's any
caffeine in this tea either which makes
it more tiring oh man okay where are the
questions okay I play again spectators
maybe I'll play later but I did like I
did plan this Q&A in advance sometimes
when people ask me questions I just tell
them to ask them during Q&A so I'm
trying my best
cuz I go over an Enzo Larson what does
nimza Larson is that b3 I will say I
know very little about names of Larson
hey it's you not just usually the bits
come with a question
you got just just giving me bits for
free thanks you got Jess whoa more bits
Sara millio with 500 bits
well if you guys have questions let me
know
ah
Kiyomi asking could I go over how to
create imbalances maybe in a position
like exchange French yeah that's an
interesting question let me make a new
chapter
creating imbalances in exchange French
which is one of the most boring openings
ever yeah so an imbalance in chess is
just like a difference between both
sides and it can come in many different
forms in terms of okay material
imbalances pawn structure space minor
pieces like night forces bishop
sometimes like king safety these are all
types of the advantages or differences
to be aware of in this sort of positions
very symmetrical there's really no
imbalances apart from the fact that
white has extra tempo what I like to
show like let's say we're playing black
and we're trying to be the high rated
player and let's say white just goes for
some normal development scheme like
something like this not f3 Bishop d3 and
castling one way to go for some
imbalance just uh just Castle queenside
like mega the shark game and black has a
lot of flexibility in terms of the setup
so if you're a French player and you
want to play something aggressively from
this position I can recommend starting
with Bishop d6 and then putting the
knight on e7 this way if white ever
plays Bishop g5 you can respond with f6
let's say the bishop moves back then you
play knight c6 let's say what castles in
Bishop g4 and the plan very soon is
Queen d7 and castling and
yeah any student who plays a French I
recommend them to learn the setup
because it can be very fun to play going
for it in the middle game where it's
going to be a sharp position like let's
say what completes development I get
some position like this
I think the attack is actually easier
for black because g5 can come with tempo
and then H 5 H 4 could attack the bishop
and maybe further down the road open
some some files but again it depends
like sometimes sometimes based on the
specific position there's there's
different ways to create imbalances I
think the the best resource so like
fully answer this question is a book
reassess your chess by Jeremy Solman or
it's just completely dedicated to like
all the different types of imbalances
and chests and how strong your players
can essentially outplay weaker players
from different types of positions what
you look after if someone plays a cos
rabbits and you're playing black pretty
sure there is there's a very key move
that if you're a patch off player and
you run into the Cochran gambit is
essentially one move - no pretty sure
the move is d5 but I'm not sure when
so let's investigate yeah if you play
the Petroff you should know what the COS
from gambit is unless you play the
staffer gambit you play knight c6 if you
don't have to worry about the the koshen
gambit but Katherine comes after d6 and
then Knight takes f7 and like gambit
some nights and it's kind of similar
style to Halloween gambits it's not
sacking a pawn attacking a whole piece
to take over the center you get some
initiative
so pretty sure white plays d4 here at d4
there's some trap do not take on you for
because Queen h5 and then Queen d5 and
you lose the piece back with a bad
position oh maybe it's c5 maybe this is
enough yeah and like this is something I
honestly don't really know much about
but it's usually pretty straightforward
to figure out with the Masters database
c5 do you take c5 ah now here d5 you can
verify the stockfish to d5 scores
amazingly for black if it sock fish
approved play d5 odds are white will be
not so well prepared as this is a pretty
offbeat line you probably have to know
further like be 5 y is oh it's being
weird so Knight g4 or Queen e8 are both
playable this looks nice this pawn is
weak
curious if Bishop f4 ah so we're tagging
this pawn we also want to take this pawn
in target f2 so black is essentially
getting initiative and is up a piece if
you can take on c5 play rook a fade in
castle life is so good up a piece and
some attack so okay hopefully that
answers the question a little bit again
I would encourage you to to dig deeper
like use the combination of stock fish
and opening reference can be a good
solution if you don't have like an
opening book or video to kind of fall
back on
were there bits there were bits a tuna
was there a question I don't know ah
there was a question oh you got just
asked if I can discuss pawn play when to
push and the fine line of overextending
I should have a study for this it really
comes down to like specific examples I
could maybe give some example the ala me
given one example or a couple examples
emerging from Sicilian law and play when
when one and when not to wait I can't do
grammar when to push okay
let's imagine we're planting black or
we're playing whites okay let's say
we're playing whites and it's some
opening
first of all let's say black plays
Knight f6 here and this will be
interesting let me give the the twitch
chat some some exercises
so people you have to stop asking
questions just for a moment and now I'm
going to ask some questions first
question should white push ePHI good
move or bad move
is it overextending like weakening white
or is it justified okay people saying
bad always push wait did i specify
good move very bad move yeah always
listen to Yasser pushing baby I'm
actually surprised how many people are
saying bad move in this case II 5 is
very much justified this is a great move
this is the best move the most
tremendous move essentially what white
is doing here is gaining time on the 9th
and the reason why this isn't really
weakening for white or overextending I
mean the pawn is well supported by the
Knights and black won't have any
attackers and like this Knight doesn't
have a great square to move to if the
knight moves to d5 then white can play
Knight c3 attacking the knight again if
black takes white takes back such a
great positioning for whites ahead and
developments as pawn can have more
supports the bishops develop fluidly
like a castle I'm pretty sure there is a
game actually there's a game after black
lady 6 I think it was
Nakamura's quickest loss ever like he
lost in 12 moves let me find it yeah
this one inserts such a short game
nicknamed lion if anyone wants to see
Nakamura losing 12 movies this is a
spectacular game just to show it real
quick
Enoch I just got crushed in this game
like everything went wrong for a black
queenside castle and then Ricky want and
he just resigned like white just
developed immediately in black just
could not develop like there's threats
of this the skiing is stuck this is back
before the protest League this is a US
chassis I did give a lecture on this
game actually if you type into youtube
like Nakamura loses in 12 moves you
should probably find it let's do it real
quick Nakamura loses and 12 moves yeah
this one
okay
where did it go oh my gosh I have two
too many tabs open it's so overwhelming
there we go okay just leave this is the
comment but I want to give some more
more examples one more example of pawn
play let's say black plays Knight c6 now
e6 all right now Bishop c4 e6 Knight c3
let's say a six preparing d5 a four and
now let's say Knight f6 okay I think
this is a good example
yeah wait to move question is 'if i good
move or bad move this is similar to the
previous example where again we're just
moving forward to attack the Knights
should white play its should white do
something else it's here what what
people have to say
we have we have yeasts we have this
looks good in my eyes if now that's bad
good most definitely yes this is nice
some people will we'll learn some
valuable lessons bad move bad move bad
move good move I think terrible move I'm
quite good not winning all right let me
let me give some answer here this is
actually just a bad move e5 I think this
kind of goes back to like the definition
of a weakness really important to
understand what what a weakness is in
chess because in this case e v is is
like bound to be a weakness because it's
very easy for black to attack and it's
harder for way to the fence now the move
to play here for black in the move which
punishes e5 is Knight g4 and then the
problem emerges for whites that like
white is just kind of going to run out
of defenders like the night is already
defending that there's two attackers
only decent-looking way to defend the
pawns Queen e2 and then Queen c7 three
attackers I buy your pawn so whenever
you overextend sometimes you have to
like see the potential attackers and
potential defenders in other case black
didn't have this immediate exploitation
over the e5 pawn actually just to go
back to show in the other case if 906
and then Knight g4 there would be the
immediate h3 just came the night because
the pawns defended
but in this case after night g4y can't
play h3 because black already has the
threats and black is the ones using
initiative so sometimes when you play a
move like this you want to make sure
that you can keep initiative and that
you're not creating an unnecessary
weakness baby onion I think I answered
your question yeah and there's so many
more examples of pushing pawns if you
like these types of examples and you
want to learn more about pawn play I can
recommend a book and some look I
actually haven't read but I've just
heard great things about just type into
Google Sam Shanklin two pawns and it's
this book I think
yeah it has some clever title I'm sure
it's on Amazon too
and Sam Franklin even has some lectures
on on the Sinaloa Chess Club YouTube
channel
they're like hour-long lectures talking
about like different concepts from his
book so you guys can link some of those
to Sam Shanklin and Louis chess club or
no it's Sam Shanklin secret life of
pawns I think yeah and then you get all
the videos so yeah okay let's make a new
chapter
okay do you think training blindfold
tactics for visualization is important
how do you train blindfold tactics I
guess you would need someone to like
tell you where the pieces are because
it's not like playing blindfold chess
where you start from the initial
position yeah I would say it's probably
not the best way like if you're looking
to train visualization I would say just
play blindfold games and you can do that
in me chess a Picasso a 94 thanks for
subbing just to show like if you want to
if you want to train your visualization
and your blindfold skills you can go
preferences
mindful chess Oh people can't see now
people can see you just turn it on and
then it saves and then I think if you
start a game yeah if you start a game
though no it's mindful chess and then
you can work on your visualization
skills so I think because I started a
game and this guy is here I'll play him
only twelve okay this is a rated game
but I'll play him and I'll try and
answer more questions while playing
blindfolds see how this goes okay let's
play a petrov can you hold the position
Magnus posted on Twitter I did not see
what man was posted on Twitter oh the
song the ten year challenge I don't
think I could on a normal day
if I was really a shark and focused
maybe I could but it would be difficult
in the tournament maybe I could figure
it out but it's really good there's a
difficult position to hold okay so I'm
playing the staffer gambit
if people want to see the pieces you can
just go to watch my games I guess I
could leave a link in the chats I'm
still in preparation
and now I'll scroll up and just prevent
and look at questions that I can answer
without any analysis board this guy I
think he's giving me a pawn this looks
like a free pawn it's the best defense
against French more like what's the best
attack against the French Bishop g5 in
Bishop g5 we can trade a bunch maybe
I'll play Age 6/6
yeah my recommendation against the
French I can give a few recommendations
I mean the one that I recommend the most
is the two Knights attack I can get
suitable for any player below master
level Bishop h4 looking for some way to
be aggressive here could play g5 let's
play g5 being very aggressive I can also
recommend the wing gambit against the
French it's an interesting line so I'm
just developing I have my bishops in the
center ooh
Bishop takes he seven so he's trying to
deflect my queen from defending d4 the
problem is that I have this move check
and well when the bishop and just be
able to piece
I won the pawn back - I guess he won c7
trying to visualize where all the pawns
are please Queen f3 attacking the
Knights I could put the Queen on e5
okay so the bishop develops its Castle
queenside okay now it's time to go for
some attack try the later this game goes
the more I have to just stay focused I
don't want to forget where the pieces
are but I have some nice attack play g4
only Myrick wants to come in and listen
this
okay so I'm trying to remember where all
of white spawns are yeah I think it's
just like this and my pawns are like
what phase f3 so you'll also play f4 oh
he's defending the pawn to which I
forgot to take so let's play the roof to
g8 I couldn't take it because he has a
queen and the bishop so now he plays
that for us now I can't on passant Queen
c5 check also c3 I think is hanging let
me start with Queen c5
okay so the king goes to h1 and now I'll
play each four I'm trying to figure out
a way to break through I have the pawns
and the rooks and the Queen plays a five
so my Knights should probably move ah
there's a nice meeting idea play this
threatening some very nice like meeting
three I think don't see it please
even if he does see it it might be hard
to just neptune says the stream is laggy
we can't see any of the pieces as I'm
playing wineville chess I know there's a
way to have like the board show up
somewhere so people can see it but I
still won't be able to see it but if you
want to see the board just okay I'll
share the link in the chat again those
who just joined Queen f2 we have to is
kind of annoying
because I'm not meeting
and we can just trade because I don't
want to lose a seven pawn
yeah we'll trade and I'll probably go
for a g3 because now I'm attacking the
rook and some file will open up
if you take Sanji three I probably take
with Knight rook F 1 so I have pawns
here and here he has founds here in here
but I have my rooks and his king is here
this looks fun G takes h3 so this is a
fork I just win the rook
take with Chuck so everything is falling
apart for whites my night will take off
for next
some of these in games you really have
to keep track of where the pawns are I
think I'm just simplifying you see text
III okay the rookie game
so here's King pawn pawn pawn pawn rook
I have rook rook Bishop please rook F
once is pawns attacked
let's move the bishop back there's still
a pawn in each - I'm not mistaken which
I'm about to win
d for where is the king o the Kings on
III so maybe there's some mating idea
like King out for rook g4 is inmates
pretty sure yeah okay it takes work
so like just stay focused but it's it's
a training exercise I can recommend for
people who want to try and practice like
remembering where everything is just to
show the game my opponent was very
generous to me giving me some some free
gifts in the opening mainly the d4 pawn
I am thinking of like making a new VHS
account just dedicated to blindfold
chess so I think it would be interesting
like what my ratings would be especially
like blitz and bullets would be much
lower than normal yeah I hope you got
Jess appreciates my my pawn player in
this game yeah for those who weren't
observing and couldn't keep track these
pawns advanced pretty far I pushed them
because they were supported by both
rooks and because White's King is here
so even if I like lose one of them files
open up sometimes that's one of the main
reasons you push pawns is just to open
files so what I really wanted let me
turn off the engine
arrows in this position Queen f2 is a
good kind of defense to move so if white
plays any other like normal-looking move
there's a 93 which is a nice puzzle
puzzle rush type problem it takes takes
and then I would meet
that's a queen controls g1 but queen f2
okay yeah this is important because if I
wasn't paying attention and I play this
and there's this and white has counter
play so yeah this is a fun position I
don't know what white should play here
yeah it's it's pretty difficult like
Bishop d5 is coming - OH
93 after Queen f2 I considered this but
ah I forgot that wait what did I forget
oh no I don't think I forgot anything I
was thinking if takes and okay
Plaquemine is a queen here but why can
just play king g1 and yeah i don't know
if there's any like great follow up like
I don't think I can even win the rook
lift takes and rook takes otherwise I
have to move the Queen but then I lose
the Knights
okay so that was fun
max villager back in the chats
welcome back axe villager click on your
profile name pieces blindfold I think my
if I make a new accounts actually I
don't want to say what the name would be
because I'm someone like copy it before
I create it
I'll keep its secrets maybe I'll just
keep it secret and then like eventually
people will find out any tips for being
quicker with coordinates yes this is
going to be fun to answer so whenever I
teach like these actor II school like
chess classes where there's like bunch
of kids and they're hard to control I
like to teach and then sometimes you you
don't have access to one but I like to
teach in like one of these rooms with
like the smart board with the
touchscreen and usually what I do is
have them practice coordinates and I'll
load up me chests and I'll show them
this game with the touchscreen so they
have to like run around and touch the
coordinates I think the big projector
essentially you have to click the
coordinates without having access to the
pieces or the letters and numbers I
should say so like if you get good you
can do it relatively quickly this is
also good for testing Mouse speed pretty
sure and routing is like ridiculous of
this game I'm so slow 78 487 17 and you
can flip you can do it from black side
to okay let me try and be competitive
here I'll try and break 33 he's
reasonable
she's seven
hey there anytime feel like there's
people that like break 50 maybe even
break 60 I was watching another xtreamer
Pesce who's like one of the I think he's
top in the world for eight-year-olds and
he was doing this the other day and he
broke like I know he broke 50 it was
pretty ridiculous like watching him just
so fast
did he get 70 I mean I wouldn't be
surprised I in 39
maybe he seems impressive but others
players who can do it much faster baby
onion can I challenge you where you play
against my Italian yes did baby onion
challenge me or he was asking permission
thanks for my tips against French did I
give tips against French oh I wanted to
show the wink and it's against the
French where did my study
just closing tabs here I think I've a
loss to study
also yeah thanks for the bits I don't
know what your name is but thank you
okay so we have we have the study wing
gambit against French just to show I
won't go too deeply but if you want to
play some crazy line against French you
can play d4 in this position and C takes
b4 a3 am idea is you trade off blacks
Bishop a clock ticks and you take it's
very hard to stop night be 596 if a six
you still go night be five so it's an
interesting line if black doesn't take
and plays this and you do this this and
you get this nice kind of structure
where black doesn't have c5 and your
pawns are just so good and there's
compensation so it's similar to some
Bank of style gambits
oh you have a problem keeping your lead
in pieces that's one of the problems
with being on material when you have
more pieces in your opponent's there's
more things to potentially lose so you
have to be careful I mean one strategy
is just to continually look for your
opponent's threats and before you make
any move let you look at your opponent's
ideas and their what they're attacking
this is what we call blunder checking
where you're just looking for for
landmines ensuring that things are are
well controlled so baby onion your name
is gch 82 okay I'll play you and I'll
I'll go into your Italian I'm black
weights I want my I want to see the
board I want to be alright I want to
make this a bit more viewer friendly
let's go back and no blindfold refresh
okay so we're playing against baby
onions Italian do I have any theory
against the grub
after this game I'll try and show it's
so baby onion just told me to play this
and now I think I'll be free to do what
I want this is just very standard stuff
so far and we're okay we're gonna have a
very symmetrical position takes me back
to childhood so this is maybe the first
moment where I have a couple options
like a sling is most normal than white
construct first with like Bishop g5 in
95 so there's a couple ideas here for
black one idea is to play 95 and just
get the bishop pair with all their idea
is to play Bishop g4 and 94 oh you were
hoping for two nights maybe I'll have to
play you in another game I want to do
this I'm gonna be aggressive mighty for
coming also thanks for the bits the wood
layer with numbers disguises letters
those bits are gonna buy some pot tie
later all these questions that's working
up I'm working up in appetites yeah so
h3 I mean it's a move but it doesn't
really solve much I guess why could
maybe go for this if white plays g4 I'll
consider taking it might be a good good
sacrifice g4 takes takes takes and then
this is a monster threat
if you love pod time you should you
should subscribe and then you get the
pod Thai emotes pod tie is great
there should be three that's a decent
move because now if I played 94 just
takes it so I think I'll just play 94
anyway and then just look to get the
bishop pair I show Queens gambit
accepted as lights I mean there's some
very basic traps if I remember I can try
to show something I also have to
remember to show the Grob okay so Rob in
Queens gambit we'll see how long this
stays in my memory a four I'm gonna play
a six there's a little bit weird idea of
a six I want to make sure this Bishop
stays on the board for a while it's
always very nice when especially a
position like this might trade it off
the dark squared Bishop keeping my own
dark squared Bishop I'm very tempted to
go for like g5g for this is another
concept Sam Shanklin talks about in his
book the concept of a hook because
White's committed to h3 and g4 will I
guarantee the the G file to open up okay
I can't resist
it's an elephant trap good I mean it's
good if the opponent walks into it even
if they don't walk into it it's still
very playable okay now do I go
completely insane
so conflicting let's do it
Yolo this is probably a dubious
sacrifice and g5 was probably dubious
why do I have a London emotes London's
my favorite opening and it's one of my
favourite cities to the chat knows the
chat knows very well
ah there is a question earlier what's
your fave opening yeah a lot of these
questions I feel like have been answered
accidentally so I could take take to
wait so it takes takes takes takes takes
rip be one I'm down a piece if Knight f6
exists I'm down a piece I could do this
then I'll be down to pieces so now I
have to fight back from probably what's
going to be a bad position I'm looking
for counter play yeah I think I'll go
and just take the stuff play Queen f6
a g5 was overly careless I think white
should have played Queen a3 first
because now point f6 I defend and I'm
preventing Queen f3 I have some pawns I
haven't lost a single pawn and my e pawn
is now a beep on
so we're gonna see some more pawn play
this game
I hope you got justice still watching
because I have to make use of my pawns
like I have any pawns on my up you can't
counts White's missing two pots so I'm
up I'm up two pawns they call Castle
queenside oh that's a dangerous move
though she wants to take I also wants to
play e5 d4 is very strong don't really
want to Castle kingside
now this is tough
okay losing a pawn back I'll have one
pawn for a bishop I could very well lose
this game hey it's more bits play
yeah my rooks are sad but at least
they're connected it's not another pons
attacks now where is my pawn living I'm
gonna sack another pawn sometimes pawns
are just getting in the way of opening
files so what I want to do here I want
to open the a file so my rook can come
to a3 and then eventually up here h3 and
then the eventual goal is to meet let's
play c5 more pawn play it's what we call
pawn tension POSIX oh there's so much
pollen tension so confusing I have to
take I think I can choose which pawn to
take
I'll put the Queen on f4 I mean I just
want to play c4 and kill White's extra
piece I think this rock on b2 is not
looking so great that's a good move
though okay let's put the rook here
actually I don't know if Fischer d5 was
good cuz now it's a little bit stuck
Queen up three okay
Oh think we're not three is I mean quit
after me looks like it's almost saving
light but I have this smooth now and I
think I'm winning back a piece that's a
miracle
yeah my opponent is clearly not cheating
and just a disclaimer I don't really
support people all right I don't really
recommend people saying or accusing
someone of cheating without sufficient
evidence yeah and baby onion I mean
there's been a viewer for a long time
trusted viewer - he is playing some good
news though but the momentum is shifting
okay let's take a bishop if I take with
the rook there's rook t1 which is really
troublesome
so I have to take with the Queen and
we'll probably have some rockin do
yeah my pond advantage kind of
disappeared but at least White's Bishop
disappeared miss pawn was weak
so the pollen count is equal I was
talking about some overextended pawns
earlier it's 'if i find very
overextended my g5 pawn prevents white
from playing f4 so I'll go up a pawn you
don't want to play each six first
there's no rush to take some lines were
white playing h6 would be annoying okay
yeah I see the question about must no
openings but I like the answer from Yago
it does depend on like what your
repertory is because I mean I I would
say there's there's not really a must
you know opening in chess because
there's so many options so many playable
options for both sides and sometimes it
depends what the opponent is playing to
I mean for pure beginners must-know
opening is how to not get scholars made
okay I think this is a winning King pawn
ending
I just can't flag thankfully there's
increments this is also casual too so no
rating on the line
yeah I've only played well like he
definitely capitalized on this g5 move
each three g4 was was played at the
right time but then okay and blitz
Chester is always going to be these of
plunger type moments it all it takes is
one oversight like Bishop d5 already
it's a little bit tricky for whites I
was thinking in this position maybe
Bishop Eve or Queen takes B 2 and then
Queen f5 actually Bishop e4 might save
White's because I don't think I can
allow this Messiah rookie Yates it gets
complicated pretty quickly I probably
won't want to go into this the bishop e4
would have been interesting I feel bad I
didn't play the two knights like he
wanted me to play some specific opening
well I would play one more game where
you cuz I'm curious what he wants to
play against me but other people are
challenging me too
we have a question saying may I ask you
some questions yes you may
okay so 6-pounder you're a moderate mm
rated player would be happy to jump to
2300 notice one of my weak points it's
still the opening tips on how to
effectively learn openings I've been
talking a lot about this the stream like
learning openings using like some
opening database combined with stock
fish I've talked about this in the past
too about like building rapport order
either using me chess or chess base
well one video which maybe would help
which I can link to let me go back to my
Q&A study chat keep losing this study
tips for learning openings I've been
covering a lot of random stuff so if
anyone wants like go and look over what
I've been covering I'm leaving the study
link in the chat again for this chapter
I'll just link one of my recent youtube
videos hopefully it pops up
yeah it's called building an opening
repertoire using we just oughta work and
that video I give tips on like how to
save things and stay organized so
hopefully that will be of some use
but yeah at a higher level it can be a
bit different
like if you're already above 2000
sometimes it's about committing to one
line and staying consistent and not
spreading yourself too thin if you're
playing a bunch of different things and
sometimes it's hard to learn one thing
really well so I'd recommend maybe
spending some time choosing what to
pursue and then staying persistent and
playing a lot of games and continually
expanding on especially on the lines
that you run into often every game you
should expand maybe a little bit in your
opening rapper tour
okay somehow this LinkedIn's Google is
being weird with links let me actually
paste in the video oh it does so I don't
know why it does that
was this really struggling with links
okay I just wanted to invade normally
there we go okay and I subscribe to
PewDiePie I don't know I don't really
want to check I was watching one of his
videos earlier though he was giving tips
for youtubers this interesting video
I know that there were a ton of
questions I missed earlier
can i play Alec are as black as black
now people are just asking me to play
stuff okay we'll play someone let's play
this guy in the middle I'll pre move
Knight f6 if he plays efore your wish
will come true hey its bits do I play
the black Mardy Murie gambits almost
never but again but I do play is a
budapest gambit what time control would
I recommend for a novice player trying
to improve your 1500 but haven't
ventured oh your 1500 in blitz play at
least like 15 minutes then you have time
to I think at least during critical
moments because blitz you really have to
rely on intuition and a lot of games
come down to time scrambles so 15
minutes I think is a nice nice spot to
do consistently or 15 plus 15 whatever
games you can start like easily from the
homepage okay so we have one of the main
line do the pass variations it's
important to note Bishop c5 provokes III
so this Bishop gets stuck now will win
the pawn
I showed this in a YouTube video I think
earlier this month at the very beginning
of the month where the middle game plan
for black actually I won't see it
because it's about to happen usually
black just castles and it's important to
avoid playing g6 too early as we'll see
start with rookie eights do I upload the
stream to YouTube I'm behind with
youtube uploads because it takes effort
to export an edit and then like export
again and then upload and do all the
description stuff I need to hire someone
to do that for me oh maybe I'll probably
put this on YouTube maybe I'll just put
it as like a just its own stream and not
do any editing
we'll see how do I change my pot where
people can share certain types of links
if someone's linking them each a study
I'd want I'd wanted to stay I'm sorry
for a night but being overly powerful 94
is a good move it's one of the reasons I
played rookie 8 is to allow Bishop F
eights
Olli chess links are allowed okay
I think there's only a few people that
have control over my night BOTS okay so
the middle game plan for black is rook
h6 and checkmates a queen d4 i mean
queen d4 creates this battery of a the
bishop defends g7 so i'll go for this
I'm not afraid my rook will be trapped
like white would have c5 to attack the
room but it's hard to attack the rook on
each six and it's only after the rook
swings over that next I want to play d6
and get my bishop into play and soon get
my queen into play it's a fun plan so
Queen h4 could be plated immediately
let's do it
I'm aligning the queen with the Knights
there might be ideas there's actually
two threats with Queen each [ __ ] I mean
the obvious threat this but then another
threat which I don't think White's
stopped which is this attacking the
night and attacking the Queen
sighing black is winning a piece I
always play Bishop I face a better the
bishop on I fade it so clutch allowed
the night not to be pinned and now now
things are being attacked left and
rights
yeah I apologize people lose questions I
did not answer especially earlier I it's
hard to give thorough answers and answer
everything okay let's take a night the
Queen and I'll probably shift the rook
over to g6 and target g2 unless white
plays Bishop back three and then and
then I have to deal with it I would love
to play Bishop b4 soon dozen I get
meaning so if I have the time I'll play
rook g6 threatening me
Oh he plays Bishop a3 I mean it's okay
I'm off a piece this is not a position
to overthink put the Queen back super
safe and then I'll go for this and then
this and then that's maybe or maybe this
I don't know I'm self-taught but I don't
think I know there's a real target for
me the other yeah uh yeah if you have
some goal of like attaining some title
or some reading it's okay to have a goal
like that but you also want to have
there's more you want to have like some
like study goals where instead of aiming
for a specific reading you're aiming for
like solving a certain number of puzzles
everyday or playing a certain number of
training games are certain number of
tournament games every so often because
those are very like much more attainable
easier to accomplish and that that will
help you get to your eventual rating
goals or title goals
okay let's fit this was 17 queen g6
better maybe 17 queen g6 but I want my
work on g6 I mean I would be threatening
this but I could move the King
okay so we're trading Bishop takes c6
makes me very happy because now there's
I mean the only white piece on the King
side is white scheme and I have most of
my pieces aimed at the King side laying
in bed eating ramen and watching Eric
what's better
I mean pot thai is way better than ramen
way better this is a free pawn what's my
opinion about Philidor for black oh
Philidor black line opening I know very
little about it I even asked it asked
about it many times before but I think
objectively at like high levels it's
just kind of passive for black but maybe
it's playable h6 g5 is something I'd I
don't know like off the top of my head
Bishop a4 important to discover check
block the rook and Queen h4 his mate
maximum how is a low compared to blitz
rating it varies from Player to Player
some players are better at let's some
players are much worse a blitz compared
to their their classical rating you've
started to play two months ago you
haven't played anything besides blitz
and bullets because you only play online
yeah I will say like online play is a
lot different than my classical over the
board play
I've had like a good number of students
who play exclusively online don't play
in tournaments and then it's interesting
to see like when they play and over the
board tournament how they do and one
student comes to mind that he was like
nineteen hundred and online loads I
think over the board let's say he's like
fourteen or fifteen hundred us rated so
maybe about like fifteen sixteen hundred
in and Phoebe I could have won that
exchange I could have taken the Huracan
G to there were more important things in
life you have a box of POD tie in your
pantry yeah I mean if you have a box you
should make it does this is pod tie
supposed to come in a box that sounds
wrong it should come I mean it should
come from a Thai restaurant that's
usually the best place or in the form of
like Street food but I mean it's better
than nothing you're purely online player
but what élow do you think nineteen
hundred rapid player would have probably
fifteen hundred fifteen to sixteen
hundred I'd say like ballpark but I
don't know I mean it could fluctuate
again for player for different types of
players but I will said I don't think
nineteen hundred online would be
nineteen hundred feet a I think there's
at least a three to four hundred point
drop
but then for me I guess like my my VHS
ratings kind of correspond with my
feeder ratings let's see
now my ultra bullet rating corresponds
pretty well within 20 to 30 points and
my blitz and my rapid what's my feet are
eating as I took a hit like my recent
tournaments
I lost points I'm twenty three thirty
eight yeah so my my blitz in a rapid are
pretty close to a few day when's the
next viewer tournaments right now no
just kidding I don't know I needs a
schedule one I could do a poll you do
like a Google forum maybe tomorrow I
have anything planned for tomorrow I
think I'll do one tomorrow viewer
tournament I'll do one around this time
hopefully most people will be happy with
that those watching maybe those who
aren't watching right now it won't be
happy with that viewer tournaments i
typed in viewer and it autocorrected to
viruses it's not a good omen
let me change this to my chest calendar
what's a preferred time control do
people prefer i mean i've been i so i
didn't want a viewer tournament with 5
plus 0 i did another one with 7 plus 0 i
could also do 3 2 I could do 10 0
anything longer it would be a bit too
much
don't work I'm curious now if it updated
like automatically if I just go to my
website it's not loading ah there it is
so I do have a schedule ident updates
usually when I add an event it takes
like one to two hours to appear Google
Calendar slow it's syncing
so people want oh man it's good variety
of things 5 + 3 5 + 3 5 + 3 5 + 0 10 + 0
so 10 plus 0 is is good for commentary
but then it just encourages buzzer King
I could turn off the circle for the
tournaments I couldn't I could create
the tournament right now
yeah let's create the tournament play
tournaments yeah and I mean this applies
to anyone who like if you ever want to
create your own tournament you can this
is great feature on me chess anyone can
do this you don't have to have any
special privileges yeah I have to
remember all the settings though so 10
okay it looks like most people want 10
plus 0 so I will make this 10 plus 0
and to make it fair for everyone in
terms of tournament points I'm going to
restrict Boozer King because mostly
chess tournaments people will desert but
no buzzer King
so no adding of points I hope that
doesn't cause some some issues I guess I
can make it casual to do people want
casual or rated
three plus okay so I guess I'm going no
increment really casual oh man this is
not a good system to just rely on the
chat don't care really rated rated I
think graded slightly wins what are the
sub saying I'm not only gonna look at
sub responses rated rated casual oh we
are a fickle Bunch I could flip a coin I
have a coin in my pocket okay heads or
tails if I say heads or tails there's
gonna be so many comments like heads and
tails oh this is pretty simple okay so
this is a Thai coin this is ten baht
this is a head and this is a tail
wait okay you ready now I'm going to
show this I'm not touching the coin wait
I didn't even call the so it is in his
heads but what does that mean
I don't know what does heads mean I
guess heads means casual writes this
heads been rated wait let's do this
again okay so head heads is casual one
more time
heads casual up its tails
I'm not lying so it's going to be rated
don't even see the rating setting Oh
duration duration should be maybe two
hours right two hours I could make it
like I can be good six hours let's make
it two hours struggling and then it's
converted two hours here two hours yeah
that's fine
no password oh yeah so this is rated
okay then the hardest part is a custom
start date I was struggling with this
earlier whoa let's get know where that
came from
was that there the whole time it's
supposed to pop up but it's not popping
up I might have to go to Chrome I have
to like we just want 11 p.m. or know we
want 9 p.m. great new tournaments
yeah so it gave me invalid timestamp ah
now I get it okay
I had this bug earlier to where like it
wasn't showing up and now what's today
today's Tuesday wait
so at island time so tomorrow is Tuesday
what is this me chest you're supposed to
be good with not having bugs man its man
I know it's Monday for some people but
no tomorrow's Tuesday for me let's just
start over because it's being annoying
I'm really struggling here
oh it's saved everything though that's
nice have settings undefined
are there any lightly chests mods for
admins and the chats to help me I just
want to oh there we go okay it's working
so Tuesday
I assume this is local time for me I
sold you 9:00 p.m. thailand time
that's a nice interface beautiful now I
have to change the time control 10
minutes rated no buzzer King and creates
what oh I forgot to change this so two
hours that's a nice feature nice nice
job beach house for not allowing me to
create a bogus tournament like that did
the clock time save it did nice okay
create new tournaments
9:00 p.m. beautiful if people want to
join leaving the link here
I turned is irking off that was my
decision because you guys made enough
decisions for me I will also share the
link in my calendar when I when I'm able
to copy/paste it's ok I think that's
enough work for now passed upon 99 I'm
still in Thailand's heading to Portugal
in a few days
one side note though when people click
the link to go to the tournament the
tournament link the time zone or the
time should update to whatever their
local time is so most people should see
a different time than 9 p.m. why is it
starting in 21 hours because I say so ok
I think I'm ending it there pass one
ninety-nine offering to mod sure I'll
mop TAS pas 99 doesn't hurts with great
mods comes great responsibility
yeah I'm not going to Singapore at least
soon I was I flew through Singapore not
too long ago I was there a few times
last year I'll probably be back at some
points okay so I'm ending it there one
last thing ah yeah I have a very very
very important announcement
oh and Patrick James he just got here
it's very bad timing so yeah I just
wanted to say that